que souhaiterait tout de même dire à
quel point un début de crise les mérites
et offrons de cette crise sanitaire sans
aucune munition nous étions présents
comme pour les gilet jaune d'ailleurs
nous avons apaisé les choses pendant
cette crise sanitaire
nous nous sommes battus dès le départ
lorsqu'il n'y avait pas de masque nous
sommes débrouillés pour que les
associations etc en en cause en
construisent petit à petit nous avons
mis en place des tests
le conseil départemental le conseil
régional nous sommes arrivés localement
régionalement à faire en sorte de se
battre plutôt que de donner des
contraventions
pourquoi ne faisons nous pas confiance à
ces des locaux
c'est avec de tels comportements
dirigiste autoritaires comme yeux un
produit les jeunes et au pire les
électeurs extrême
donc à un moment donné il faudra bien se
rendre compte que les mères qui étaient
présents il faut pas ensuite les oublier
il faut pas ensuite les diriger les
considérer comme des simples guichets de
l'état donc ce que j'essaie de dire ce
que j'essaie de dire dans ce monde
d'ailleurs pas gravité mais ce taddei ce
monde prestigieux des idées des
essayistes démographe des historiens et
des grands politologues
moi qui ne suis qu'un simple mais
roubles de terrain jeudi qu'à un moment
donné si le président de la république
et le premier ministre ne se rendent pas
compte que c'est ici en provence mais
dans les autres provinces aussi que les
français vont trouver la force aussi de
réagir à ce moment là plutôt que
déconfinement moyenâgeux qui plombe
l'économie qui plombe le système social
et même humaines de la france peut être
qu'à ce moment là par un apaisement des
choses par une une présence un peu moins
autoritaire mais un peu plus démocrate
on arrivera peut-être à ce que la france
réagit ce mieux et que la décision
d'interdiction ne soit pas comprise
comme une décision médicale mais comme
une décision politique partagée par tous
les français
[Musique]